tu prépares plein de salive dans ta
bouche ok quand on a assez tu craches
dans le pâté tu laisse couler ta salive
dans le flacon toute la matinée ce sont
184 élèves volontaires sur 224 qui ont
effectué des tests salivaires dans cette
école élémentaire clerbois à rambouillet
suite à l'apparition de cas dans les
écoles maternelles la mairie et
l'éducation nationale ont demandé de
faire des tests dans les quatre écoles
du quartier
je pense que ces tests salivaires arrive
à point parce que dans notre école
il ya une enseignante donc qui a été
testée positive hier
et puis vu qu'il ya eu des cas et
notamment à une dans l'une des écoles
maternelles à côté voilà ça peut aussi
faire un point c'est une sécurité auront
plus et puis pour un test qui est qui
somme toute pas invasif c'est encore une
fois c'est laisser du temps pris sur les
apprentissages mais c'est un moindre mal
par rapport à la situation
le test est simple il suffit de cracher
dans un petit bocal
il sera ensuite envoyés en laboratoire
les résultats arrivent en 24 heures un
test beaucoup plus appréciés par les
enfants font saliver dans un bocal et
c'est pas du tout dérangé ou des agrafes
comparé à août est besser si pour faire
avancer un peu les choses et surtout
pour savoir si on doit fermer les écoles
ou non comme ça je peux protéger ma man
ou qui aiment y est pas très en forme et
ça permet de voir s'ils proviennent pas
les enseignants en contact permanent
avec les élèves ont tous eux aussi fait
le test même si on applique évidemment
les gestes barrière dans l'école on est
quand même avec eux tout le temps et
c'est important de se faire tester de
savoir qui dans l'école mais positif ou
pas résultat deux cas positifs ont été
détectés dans deux classes différentes
ce qui entraîne directement leur
fermeture puisque le nouveau protocole
sanitaire mise en place par jean michel
blanquer
dès ce lundi 29 mars prévoit la
fermeture d'une classe entière lorsqu'un
seul cas de kobe de 19 est détectée dans
les dix-neuf départements confiné